let's say that we're told this some
right over here where our index starts
at two and we go all the way to infinity
that this infinite series is negative
8/5 plus sixteen over seven minus
thirty-two over nine plus and we just
keep going on and on forever and so what
I want to do is find is to explicitly
define what a sub n here is here so
right now we just say if you take the
sub of a the sum of a sub n from N
equals two to infinity it turns out you
get this sum right over here but let's
think about what a sub n how we can
actually define it in terms of N and I
encourage you to pause the video right
now and try it on your own so the first
thing that you might realize is well
this is the number that we're going to
get this is the number that we're going
to get let me write it this way a sub 2
a sub 2 is equal to negative 8/5 a sub 3
a sub 3 is equal to 16 is equal to 16
over 7 a sub 4 is equal to negative 32
negative 32 over 9 and I'm just I'm just
giving the sign to the number in the
numerator negative 8/5 is the same thing
as negative 8 over 5 let me make that a
little bit clearer so make that a little
bit clearer so this is negative 8 over 5
obviously this is positive so I don't
have to really worry about too much and
then here I'm just saying negative 32
over 9 to the same thing as negative 32
over over 9 so let's see let's see if we
can first find a pattern in the
numerator a pattern in the numerator so
when we go from negative 8 to 16 what's
happening well we're multiplying we're
multiplying by negative 2 we're
multiplying by negative 2 now to go from
16 to negative 32 we're multiplying by
negative 2 multiplying by negative 2
again so you might say okay well
whatever we have in the numerator must
be a power of negative 2 all right if
you say well maybe this is negative 2
squared well you know that negative 8
isn't negative 2 squared negative 2
squared is equal to positive 4 negative
8 this right over here negative 8 that
is equal to negative 2 to the third
power 16 is equal to negative
two to the fourth power negative 32 is
equal to negative negative two to the
fifth power so notice our exponent on
the negative two is always going to be
one more one more
than our index our Nexus to our exponent
is 3 our index is 3 our exponent is 4
and Nexus 4 our exponent is 5 so that
gives a sense at least the numerator the
numerator is going to be whatever our
index is is going to be so let me write
this down so a sub n a sub n is equal to
well it's going to be negative 2 to
whatever index we're at to that index
plus 1 power so that's one way to think
or that's a reasonable way to think
about our numerator now let's think
about our denominators so over so we go
from 5 so when n is 2 we're at 5 when an
N is 3 where it's 7 when n is 4 we're at
9 so notice 5 is 2 times 2 plus 1 is 2
times 2 2 times 2 plus 1 this right over
here is 2 times 3 plus 1 this right over
here is 2 times 4 plus 1 and you should
just kind of play around with different
patterns in your head until you say hey
well look this is let's you know this is
increasing by 2 every time notice this
increases by a by 2 every time but these
aren't exactly these aren't exactly
multiples with 2 these seem to be off by
off of 1 more than the multiples of 2
which is a good sign that this is going
to be 2 times our index plus 1 so we
could write this down we could write
this down as 2 times our index plus 1
and we're done that's what a sub n is
and if we wanted to write this series in
Sigma notation we would write this as a
sum from N equals 2 to infinity of
negative 2 to the n plus 1 power over 2
and plus 1 and that would equal this
series right over here